so microsoft sent me an email and said
hey we have a flight simulator kit for
you
would you like to receive it and i
could not type yes fast enough the kit
arrived i have absolutely no idea what's
in here so we're gonna just kind of open
it up
this feels like one of those old school
unboxings where i actually have
absolutely no idea what is in this oh my
god oh god
this is so much bigger than i thought it
was gonna be am i even in the frame
hello do i need to zoom out on this oh
my god
it's ridiculous okay well yes we are
zooming out all right
i guess i just start from the top i love
that they have like little stickers
all over the place of different
destinations
you should never cut towards yourself
can you see that
it says flight simulator how do i even
show you
what i'm doing we have a logitech
throttle
you guys
there's a thrust master in here i don't
even know what that is
oh god it's so heavy it's so heavy
here's the first thing the flight
throttle quadrant
hey just seeing what you do in
quarantine learn to fly a plane what did
you do
the heck is this
is this the black box that will record
all of my flight data
has anybody seen lost this is the alpha
flight controls it's the yoke
and switch panel what's in here
are these flight sunglasses oh they
definitely are we are so excited to have
you
in the microsoft flight simulator
community the flight sim team has worked
with our partners logitech and honeycomb
and thrustmaster to provide a few
peripherals to improve your microsoft
flight simulator experience
please reach out to your local rep with
any questions with setup or otherwise
i think i can figure it out this is
incredible so these
are to help block blue light i've
actually been looking into getting a
pair of these
because the amount of time that i do
spend on screens is just absurd
it's really not good these are kind of
cute check this out these look like my
dad's
that he used to wear when i was younger
like i'm definitely getting a real dad
flashback here my dad's gonna watch this
and
be like yeah i had those there's still
something else in this box behind me
that is awkwardly stabbing me in the
back all right
this is the thrustmaster
thrustmaster has been
removed uh these glasses are so cool
i'm very much into them i think the
first thing that i will
unbox are their directions or there's
literally
just
any oh interesting the yoke and switch
panel is very important
when flying a plane
i think i could wear this
if this isn't a definition of quarantine
then i don't know what is
honeycomb aeronautical flight controls
so this is all extremely
professional grade stuff like i think
that this
this will make me a pilot we're already
here we're already up we're
i gotta land this plane the oak should
be pre-configured and ready to go we
have several new products in development
starting with
something exciting this is so exciting
this is so exciting we have instructions
so this looks like it's got a little
sticky something
so that doesn't move around when i'm
flying my plane
southwest is going to be calling and
saying hey oh my gosh
this is seriously honestly i can't even
tell this is not what i expected
maddie agrees maybe i have to set up a
whole separate desk for this because
this is
this does not seem like this doesn't
this doesn't seem like something that is
going to fit in my current streaming
area
this is so much more stuff that i've
than i thought to figure out how to put
all this together
i definitely opened it the wrong way i
think
i mean honestly most planes i feel like
potentially just fly themselves
so you know at least i'll have the
basics down
we've got one last thing to open all
right thrust master
directions put you right here
oh god have we fought we've fought i've
almost fallen
thrust thrustmaster is about to thrust
me into a
new dimension unboxing this thing i have
not fallen
i'm just visualizing myself right now
playing this okay
guess i'll leave your airspace you pig
and how terrible i'm gonna be at it
what i'm gonna start hosting flight
school
there we go
okay so we did that guess i have to
[Music]
figure out the rest of it now
no problem the flight sim is finally set
up i've done a few little live streams i
also did a live stream where i put the
webcam on my head so that you guys can
see
my point of view oh geez oh my god
your speed's picking up again as the
nose pitches down let's see what happens
when you cut all the power
rise surprise my engine food is
decreasing
this might be a good time for a piloting
psa
what's that always keep an eye on your
surroundings because nobody likes a low
flying duck
is there a duck somewhere do a barrel
roll let's go ahead and throttle back up
freezing
as long as we maintain my attitude
we'll keep climbing too
i know i'm talented like you're really
getting the hang of your control
yes i am it was a little awkward the
webcam
indented into my forehead and then i had
a headache for two days but that's okay
we're back i've done some tutorials
i feel like i'm still not a good pilot
but i appreciate all the pilots out
there who have been giving me some solid
advice
this game is so much fun and it really
adds a whole nother
dynamic and another level to it when you
have an actual setup like this
this is so crazy so right now i'm gonna
go through
and we're gonna play so the problem is
i've only done tutorials learning how to
fly on a
cessna and then yesterday when i decided
i wanted to do a flight in pittsburgh
i don't even know what plane it put me
in but it was
huge the instruments were all digital i
was
overwhelmed i'm still learning but
i'm confident one day
if there's ever an emergency on board a
flight i'm ready for it
i'm up to the challenge okay so here's
here's the sydney air oh my god this is
a big boy
this is an airbus a 320 neo i've never
flown one of these before
you can't just up and put me in a big
boy okay hold on a second i got to get
my map
up okay my map i don't know where the
airport is
overspeed over speed overspeed
over speed over speed it's saying over
speed i don't know what that means
should i start going down okay i see a c
i can't even see any of my
my things i'm nowhere near
i'm gonna hit these houses oh my gosh
i'm not doing well
no i've never flown one of these big
boys before
we're taking we're good i got it we got
to go up we got to go up do we want it
shoot no i did not do a good job
it's not good it's not good but i'll
tell you what
[Music]
shoot oh god okay
i'll tell you what it was not a good
landing
but any landing that you could walk away
from that's a good landing they also
said that a fantastic landing would be
if you can fly the plane next day here's
the thing i didn't know which
i didn't know which runway i was
supposed to fly to go on does it tell me
so this is the rudders this gives us
some turn on the flight this is the
break
oh gosh we're already we're already here
we're already up we're
i gotta land this lane it's pretty
stressful
i'm not ready i'm not ready i'm nowhere
near where i need to be
i got i don't think it's i think i'm too
close 100
[Music]
a little too close i hope this is the
right runway
retired
i failed again this game is really fun
but it feels like so much more than a
game because it actually is teaching you
to fly a plane i'm gonna
just leave it at this i've been doing
some live streams of this if you guys
want to check it out check out my twitch
channel twitch.com
ijustine and we're gonna play some more
of this any tips to become a better
pilot
i would appreciate those leave them in
the comments below
okay bye
[Music]